okay so then that means that we should
take a really hard look at some of the
positive trends
right you know so
so yeah i mean i i i i wrote i'm writing
these books for
an intellectual movement that i wanted
to be a part of and support
and after i got done writing them
there's no more that movement no longer
exists which was the intellectual dark
web
of which you guys are clearly uh members
and i don't even care if you agree
because i just go you're idw i say so um
but i mentioned this to joe rogan and he
was what's that
i said we've we've been so conscripted
into it by yes thank you yeah you're in
it um
and joe was like
no like that's a stupid word that's a
stupid name and i was like okay maybe
but like
it's like you kind of go stupid but yet
we all know who's in it
like
we all like you can kind of go you can
kind of go there's like and i was even
drawing these like
like i was like okay there's like the
pro-vaxxer idw types and then there's
the anti-vaxx idw types and it basically
overlaps with who likes trump and who
doesn't
you know and it's like is it ew left and
right or is it like relationship to
government but you kind of go you know
okay and then there's some people that
don't like each other that are in it
that's part of it
right but but nonetheless i go there's
something clearly going on that's that's
that i think is
intellectual
you know that is like a salon that's
podcasts that's that's long
that's uh what uh daniel kahneman calls
slow thinking
[Music]
it's uh it's
you know it's not fox news you know
there might be parts of tucker carlson
that are idw
but it's not it's long form it's podcast
it's thoughtful it has a kind of um
it's totally fine with gays and lesbians
and frankly with trans people um but it
will push back against trans crazy trans
activists and crazy
you know it believes in climate change
it thinks climate change is a concern we
should do something about it but it's
anti-apocalyptic
it's pushing back against the new
religion it's pushing back against the
new dogmatism
um
i think it's very serious i think it's a
very significant group of people it's
you know it's um
you all everyone knows who it is it's
barry weiss it's nellie bowles it's joe
rogan it's
it's um
uh jordan peterson it's
brett um
bretton heather it's claire layman and
collette even though those two those
guys hate each other right now because
they're fighting about kovid and part of
me goes you know kovid's it's not going
to go away in fact it's going to become
endemic it is becoming endemic um
but as an issue of debate it's going to
become a lot smaller and afterwards
there's still going to be the idw and
heather and claire will become friends
again or maybe not but but they'll still
be in the idw and there's still a kind
of
so i kind of go there's that is real and
as soon as you say as soon as you
describe who's in it and the thinking
there
you can kind of go
well it may not be mainstream it may not
be the center of the overton window
right now but it's driving this debate
it's actually leading the conversation
the new york times is describing you
know i think chris ruffo is this really
interesting person
who i've gotten to know but he's been
basically single-handedly taking taking
down critical race theory in the united
states
um you know he identifies at this point
as republican and conservative
um
but he's just clearly not like your
dad's
republican right and so or what about a
guy glenn greenwald you know like
sometimes i read glenn greenwald i'm
like he hasn't changed anything in his
view
like his views are identical to what
they were when i was reading him after 9
11.
i can't figure out anything he's changed
his mind on
still an anti-imperialist
socialist as far as i can tell um
but yet you kind of go oh it's probably
something that has changed you know like
i think there's something happening
where
us on the idw side of things or on the
kind of idw left go
hey
i don't think crime is progressive or
liberal
it seems like all the victims are like
poor
african-american
you know like or you know disadvantaged
people like
crime is bad
and then you're kind of like
well that's a pretty mainstream view
that crime is bad and and actually the
idea that crime is not bad is um
completely marginal and so you go well
idw folks
are articulating i think a new
mainstream view
it's a practical view it's pragmatic
you know joe rogan's not proselytizing
ivermectin but he took it you know and
you kind of go there's some folks in
this movement that you kind of go you're
taking some kind of you sound kind of
dogmatic dude
and probably i sound that way to people
on things like nuclear power but
you kind of go yeah ivermectin may not
be the right solution
vaccines i think are great i'm a big
proponent of vaccines but i also kind of
go
how much
more pressure are we going to put on
members of our society to get it you
know um and so you get to some kind of
prac i think you were sort of saying
constantine like
there's a practicalness here in the idw
i think the best of the idw that we want
to hold on to um and a kind of populism
too um
yeah michael you know that i think i
want to hold on so i go that has that's
right when i look for hope i go that's
where i find the hope it's in this new
media idw
cluster
the one thing i hope we can retain now
that you've you've conscripted us into
that you're the first person to ever
suggest that we are in idw and i i
gratefully accept uh that with all the
consequences that it brings but
like
the one thing that i think is very
important as a new member of the iew is
tolerance of people with different views
that's the one thing that will break it
if it's not maintained and i think covid
is rapidly stress testing that sense
that look i i i love brett and heather i
consider them friends i'm honored that
they consider us friends
i think they're wonderful people having
listened to the stuff
you know on balance i'm not sure based
on what i've read and the people i've
spoken with i'm not convinced that iver
mekton
is the answer to this issue i like joe i
think he's really cool as well
if i got coveted i wouldn't take over
mecca myself but
i i'm okay with joe taking it i think
the fact that brett thinks it's a good
idea well that's up to him you know like
there's a there's a respect for
difference of opinion i mean to me that
is that used to be the sign of
intelligent people that they're able to
disagree about important things and
retain friendships and retain mutual
respect
and that's my only hope is that we don't
lose that in this process and i do see
one or two people
straying into into territory which i do
think is unhelpful in that respect
yeah i agree and and it's and then so
you know and you kind of go
it might be that look because of course
if if idw is just we're a bunch of
people that are open-minded then it's
not really like a thing you know what i
mean then it's just it's just it's just
a bunch of nice people that have
podcasts and that's fine um
and part of me was just more ambitious
in the sense that you know i kind of was
like
i was like here's what i think the idw
should be you know in both apocalypse
never and in san francisco like i'm
going to have the argument i mean i'm
kind of like i don't know whatever i'm
not sure what it would mean to not be
tall but certainly i'll have the debate
or argument with anybody um about the
ideas in the book but for me i think the
potential of something like the idw is
to have
a view of these things and that doesn't
mean that you're like kicking people out
of the cool kids club because they are
ivermectin users
but it would be kind of more like yeah
there's kind of a recognizably idw
take on that
and that may not be possible
and if it's not that's totally fine just
you know happy to be
you know having these conversations but
it does feel to me like idw
had the potential to be something like
the
um i mean the classic intellectual
movement of late was the was really the
neocons that came out of the out of the
radical left where there was this really
influential movement the neocons that
gave rise to reagan and thatcher and
that there was needing to be something
something like that again
to kind of revive
moribund a morobund
call it center right politics for lack
of a better
descriptor but something that was not
was not exactly trumpy trumpy but
appreciated some of trump's
interventions
in the culture
not socialist but maybe appreciated some
things that bernie sanders was saying
and the need for things like universal
healthcare universal psychiatry that
kind of thing and that there would be
something at the end of it that was like
a recognizable agenda that was my that's
part of my ambition and maybe
it may not be something that we can
realize but for me i kind of go i kind
of have some faith that once i get
everybody in the idw to read my books
we'll get you all to agree that that's
the right idw agenda
[Music]
you